the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi I thought that today what I'd like to
do is to in a sense clean up a few
little things that were implied by our
last lecture things that bothered me a
little bit in which I thought were
worthy of discussing in more detail
today you may recall that last time we
discussed the inverse of differentiation
and towards the end of the lecture we
pointed out that traditionally this
operation was called the indefinite
integral now I see two points bothered
me here one is why the word integral in
other words why not just inverse
derivative and we're going to talk about
that in more detail later in the course
the other part that bothered me was the
inference of what do you mean by the
indefinite integral say as opposed to
the definite integral in essence then I
think that when you say indefinite
integral one probably assumes that there
was something called the definite
integral that exists and in norther not
to prejudice anything and not to use the
word definite integral in a context that
I don't really want it in I have
entitled today's lecture the definite
indefinite integral and let's see what
this really means now recall that last
time we used the notation that d inverse
f of X meant and that was what this is
notation we used and we said in the book
that this was denoted by integral f of X
DX and that this was called the
indefinite integral and what it meant
was it was a name for the set of all
functions G whose derivative with
respect to X was f and by the mean value
theorem we also showed what that another
name for that set was simply what this
if we knew one function whose derivative
was F call that capital F then the
family capital f of X plus C was another
name for this set of functions and by
way of a review let's do a typical
problem that we could tackle last time
let's see where the word indefinite
comes from you see in a sense the
indefiniteness comes from the arbitrary
constant C here you see let's suppose
that we know that f prime of X is x
squared and we now want to find out what
f of X looks like you see
the inverse of differentiation again we
have the derivative well we know that
one function whose derivative is x
squared is 1/3 X cubed therefore any
other function whose derivative is x
squared must differ from one third x
cubed by a constant
hence we know that f of X is 1/3 x cubed
plus a constant
and it's this C that makes this thing
called the indefinite integral you see
at this particular stage C could be any
constant whatsoever and this would still
be a correct answer that we have only
got a correct answer up to a family of
functions which differ only by a
constant now if I specify one piece of
information which is called an initial
condition shall we say in other words
let's suppose I specify that when X is
equal to x0 f of X is equal to Y sub 0
the subscript 0 here just being an
abbreviation for a beginning point in
other words I now specify one additional
piece of information well if I plug this
back into the equation before I get that
F of x0 which is y0 equals one-third x
sub 0 cubed plus c from which i can
determine that c is equal to y0 minus
one third x0 cubed now notice that x0
and y0 are given numbers consequently
see here is a particular number and c
being a constant it means that whatever
c is for one given value of x it must be
that for all so now what I can do
it replaced the indefinitely by the
definite specific value y 0 minus 1 3 x0
cubed and arrive at the fact that f of X
is that unique function the only
function that there is 1/3 X cubed plus
y0 minus 1/3 x 0 cube now there was no
more arbitrary constant in here what is
this function f of X well it's the
function whose derivative is x squared
and satisfies the condition that when X
is equal to x0 y is equal to y0 and if
you want to see that in terms of our
usual analogy of resorting to curve
plotting observe that
what we can say here is what the slope
is x squared therefore the curve has the
form y equals 1/3 X cubed plus C we now
specify that the curve passes through
the point x0 y0 that helped us determine
that C is y0 minus 1/3 x0 cubed we put
that value C back into our original
equation and we wind up with y equals
1/3 X cubed plus y0 minus 1/3 x0 cubed
and what is that particular curve
it's the curve that's characterized by
the fact that it's slope at any point X
comma Y is given by x squared and it
passes through the point x0 y0 in other
words notice then that if we know the
slope of a curve and we know a point on
the curve in other words we're going to
slope everywhere and we know a point
that the curve passes through it
shouldn't seem too surprising that we
can uniquely locate where the curve is
at any time and that's exactly what this
says we have a unique expression for
this particular curve let's see if we
can't generalize this result and talk
about instead of talking about f of x
equals x squared let's consider the
following suppose we just generalize
that we have that we're given that the Y
DX is f of X and the domain of f is the
closed interval from A to B and now what
we'd like to do is to find out what
function Y is specifically well assume
that G prime is any function whose
derivative is f and by the way this is a
pretty big assumption there was this one
thing to say let's assume that we have a
function whose derivative is f but for a
given F it may not be quite that simple
to find what G must be and we'll talk
about that in more detail as our course
unfolds but it's not always that simple
to find a function which has a given
derivative we mentioned that in our last
lecture to at any rate all we're
assuming now though is that by hook or
by crook
somehow or other we know a function G
whose derivative is f then therefore
what we conclude is that since G has the
same derivative as
why that y must be G of X plus a
constant
now his weather would initial condition
comes in we're studying this problem at
x equals a say x equals a what we assume
is the curve has to be someplace when x
equals a let's call that y-coordinate Y
of a in other words Y of a is equal to G
of a plus C from which we determine that
C is equal to Y of a minus G of a you
see the only indefinite thing in here is
the y of a because you see all we're
saying is we know the x-coordinate when
X is a we and the curve can then pass
through any point whose x-coordinate is
a and all we're saying is let's call the
y coordinate of that point y of a at any
rate knowing what C is we now have that
Y of X is G of x plus y of a minus G of
a now in particular from this you see
notice from this we can now find out
what Y of B is namely we just replace X
by B and we get that Y of B is G of B
plus y of a minus G of a again the only
thing that's indefinite over here is y
of a now to get rid of the only
indefinite part it seems rather clever
that maybe all we should do is subtract
Y of a from y of B if we do that we get
that Y of B minus y of a is G of B minus
G of a notice that another name for Y of
B minus y of a is just the change in Y
as X move from A to B in other words if
we know the derivative of Y with respect
to X and we want to find out how much Y
change by as we move from x equals a to
x equals B all we have to do is to
compute G of B minus G of a where G is a
function whose derivative is f and that
by the way that's all this notation
means over here this has read this
evaluated at the upper value minus the
value of this evaluated at the lower
value fact now I suppose the only
problem that
dangling as we said you know let's let G
be the function whose derivative is f
there are many functions whose
derivative IS F
once we know one function whose
derivative is f which function should we
use over here and what I intend to show
next is that really doesn't make any
difference that's how definite this
really is namely let's suppose that H is
any other function whose derivative IS F
well since if we use this particular
expression my claim is that the change
in Y would be H of B minus H of a the
same way as we did with G and the reason
for this is that if H and G have the
same derivative then they differ by a
constant that means that H of X is G of
X plus some constant which I denote by
c1 to indicate that this is no longer an
arbitrary constant what I'm saying is
I've picked the particular H I have the
G of the previous problem the difference
is some specific constant which I call
c1 well at any rate I could now compute
H of B which is just G of B plus c1 H of
a which is G of a plus c1 and if I now
subtract I get H of B minus H of a is
equal to G of B minus G of a because the
constant c1
drops out when I form a subtraction in
other words notice that G of B minus G
of a is a well determined number
independent of what function we choose
whose derivative is f okay and to see
what this thing means pictorially just
observe the following our geometric
interpretation is this let's suppose
that we have the curve y equals G of X
on the closed interval from A to B and
what's the property of G its derivative
is f and now we look at H of X now what
is H of X H of X is G of X plus a
constant graphically what happens to a
curve when you add on a constant you see
adding on a constant just raises the
curve in other words it displaces the
curve parallel to itself
vertically in other words with respect
to the y-axis that the constant just
lips lifts the curve in other words then
what we're saying is that when you're
measuring the change in Y observe that
it really makes no difference whether
you're talking about this or whether
you're talking about this because since
these two curves are parallel you see
the displacements over these intervals
are the same in other words all we're
really saying I guess is that these two
regions here are congruent in fact it
might be wise in a sense to pick a new
axis either way here shift this thing
over and label this the Delta Y axis and
what you're really saying is the
arbitrary constant doesn't really make
any difference because what you've
raised the curve by at this end you've
raised it at this end and consequently
the arbitrary constant drops out in
determining the change in Y well again
this may still seem abstract let's give
a physical interpretation to what we're
talking about right now let's suppose
now that we have a particle moving along
the x axis particle is moving along the
x axis we know that it's speed at any
time T is given by T squared and we know
that the particle moves for one second
in other words the domain of T here is
the closed interval from zero to one now
we know that v is DX DT therefore since
one-third T cubed has its derivative
equal to T squared X must be one-third T
cubed plus a constant and here's where
the word initial condition comes in
again we're studying this problem when T
equals zero when T equals zero
the particle has to be someplace let's
say it's at x equals x sub zero that's X
of zero you see and if we do this notice
that when T is zero X is X sub zero that
says that C is X sub zero replacing C by
X sub zero we find that the particle
moves according to the rule
x equals 130 cubed plus X sub 0 now we
can find out where the particle is when
T equals 1 when T equals 1 X is 1/3 plus
X 0 we know that when the particle
started at T equals 0 X of 0 was X sub 0
and therefore the change in X in other
words X evaluated when T equals 1 minus
X evaluated when T equals 0 is simply
what 1/3 plus x0 minus x0 or 1/3 in
other words in this particular problem
if we choose as our units say feet and
seconds if a particle moves for one
second according to the rule that is
speed and in feet per second is the
square of the time in 1 second it has
been displaced by a distance of one
third of a foot and if I want to draw
that for you let me show you what's
happening over here what we're saying is
here is a particle moving along the x
axis when we start this problem at time
T equals zero the particle is at some
point x equals x0 we observe that the
particle is at the velocity T squared
and that means it's always moving from
left to right and what we find is that
when the time is 1 the particle is now
at x0 plus 1/3 in other words in this 1
second the particle has moved 1/3 of a
foot by the right to make a little
interesting aside while we're here and
we'll come back to this in more detail
also in future lectures notice that
since V equals T squared when T is 0 the
velocity is 0 and when T is 1 since T
squared is then 1 the velocity is 1
notice that the particle starts with 0
velocity ends up with a velocity of 1
but the average velocity is not 1/2 a
foot per second in other words notice
that the particle traveled a total
distance of one third of a foot in one
second in other words the average speed
was just one third of per second and you
see notice that in this particular
problem since V is e
30 squid the acceleration is not a
constant the acceleration is 2t it's a
variable notice for example that the
time is approximately 7 tenths of a
second before the particle has would
move the half a foot C in other words
notice that when u the velocity has the
time has to be 7 tenths of a second
before the velocity is 1/2 namely when
you square point 7 you get 0.49 and
notice again the non-linearity of this
which as I say will come back to later
but I thought it was worth mentioning
and passing over here any rate let's
generalize this velocity problem because
I think it's much easier to think in
terms of distance rate and time than in
terms of slopes of curves but let's just
take a look here the generalization is
this let's suppose that we have a
particle moving along the x axis its
speed at any time is given by V equals F
of T and the time interval is from T
equals a fatigue was B we assume that
capital G is any function whose
derivative is f and we then can conclude
that therefore X must be G of T plus a
constant okay we also say okay initially
that's what not necessarily zero
initially is when we stop the problem
when T equals a X of a is G of a plus C
X of T therefore is G of T notice that C
is X of a minus G of a so X of T is G of
T plus X of a minus G of a from this
just replacing T by B I find that X of B
is G of B plus X of a minus G of a again
this is the only indefinite part here
notice by the way that this is mimicking
what I did earlier for dy/dx but I want
to go through this one more time in
terms of a more tangible physical
example at any rate if I now subtract X
of a from this result I wind up with the
X of B minus X of a is G of B minus G of
a in other words the change in X on this
time interval from A to B is determined
just by of
valuating G of B minus G of a where G is
any function whose derivative see a
rather easy way of evaluating this
particular thing now again I should
point out as an interesting physical
aside that this Delta X is a
displacement not a total distance and
I'll explain what that means but in
terms of an example you see let's
observe that in the problem that I did
over here in this particular problem
over here notice that the velocity was
always positive in given problems the
velocity can oscillate between positive
and negative meaning in terms of moving
along the x axis the particle can
sometimes move from left to right other
times it can move from collect but at
any rate but I want to point out this is
that the change in X is a displacement a
net change let me give you an example
let's suppose again that a particle is
moving along the x axis now it's speed V
is given by T minus 1 where T is between
0 & 2 now the function I'm looking for X
must differ from a constant by by a
constant from any function whose
derivative is t minus 1 in particular
one function whose derivative is t minus
1 is 1/2 T squared minus T so whatever X
is it must have what form it's 1/2 T
squared minus T plus a constant now I
want to compute X evaluated when T is 2
X evaluated when T is 0 and take this
difference because that will be the
change in X you see as T goes from 0 to
2 well at any rate you see X of 2 just
putting 2 in here gives me 1/2 of 4
which is 2 minus 2 plus C which is C X
of 0 is C and therefore X of 2 minus X
of 0 is 0 or written more symbolically
Delta X as T goes from 0 to 2
is zero in other words there is no
change in X now obviously we don't mean
the particle didn't move in this case
the four no motion the velocity should
be zero but the velocity is t minus one
let's see what really happened in this
particular problem let's to do this I
have drawn some separate graphs over
here the first one shows V in terms of T
and what this shows is what that when T
when T is between 0 and 1 V is negative
now there's nothing imaginary again
recall about an imaginary about a
negative velocity remember that since
the particle is moving along the x axis
and the positive sense of the x axis is
from left to right a negative velocity
means that the particle is just moving
from right to left so what this says is
the particle is moving from right to
left for the first second and then from
left to right for the second second also
if we now want to plot the distance
versus the time to this you see what we
see is is that X is equal to 1/2 T
squared minus T that's this particular
shape and the plus X sub 0 is our
initial condition in other words this
tells us look at when we started this
problem at T equals 0 the particle was
positioned that x equals x sub 0 and
notice what this thing seems to say this
seems to say that what you started here
then for the first second the
displacement was decreasing that means
you were moving in the negative
direction and then you reached a certain
peak here and when you get down to this
particular point you start to come back
and at the end of the second second your
displacement was exactly what it was
when you first started here and by the
way let me again mention this is not the
graph of how the particle moved the
particle is moving horizontally along
the x axis this graph is just how the
displacement looks as a function of time
in fact by the way to see how we can
eliminate the X sub 0 here I have drawn
one more
you'll notice that in our recipe we said
let's compute 1/2 T squared minus T as T
goes from 0 to 2 that was the special
case where I replaced the x-axis by the
Delta x axis in other words the curve x
equals 1/2 T squared minus T would be
this curve here in other words when X
when T is 0 x is 0 this says what the
change in X when you start the problem
is 0 because the particle hasn't moved
yet and this says what the particle
moves reaches a minimum value when T
equals 1 and when T equals 1 x equals
minus 1/2 and then comes back to 0 when
T equals 2
in other words physically what happened
here is the following we started this
problem at T equals 0 at T equals 0 the
particle had a certain displacement a
certain initial position which we'll
call X sub 0 and what happened in this
problem is that for the first second the
particle moved from right to left and
when T was equal to 1 the particle was
at the position X sub 0 minus 1/2 which
is just another way of saying it was 1/2
a unit or in this case 1/2 a foot to the
left of its starting point then during
the next second the velocity is positive
the particle doubles back returns to the
point X 0 when T equals 2 so that the
displacement meaning the net change in
position during the time interval of
this problem the net displacement the
net distance traveled is 0 it started
and finished at the same point on the
other hand the total distance traveled
is 1/2 a foot in this direction 1/2 a
foot in this direction so therefore a
total of 1 foot well you see I thought
this is a worthwhile discussion to have
on distance rate in time but I also
thought another thing was rather
important did you notice that except for
my mentioning at the beginning of our
lesson that the inverse derivative is
called the indefinite integral
that the so-called integral sign has
never appeared in anything that I've
done in other words to emphasize what I
was talking about in the last lecture
observe that I could get by wonderfully
without ever having heard of an integral
sign without ever having heard of the
phrase indefinite integral
at any rate though let me ask the
following query so to speak to sort of
lead into a summation point of view once
we invent the notation integral f of X
DX to denote the set of all functions G
whose derivative IS F why not invent a
new symbol namely what will still use
this integral sign
but now put that lower and upper bound
on this thing we'll call this the
definite integral f of X DX or the
definite indefinite integral I put these
limits on a to be to denote G of B minus
G of a where G prime is any function
whose derivative IS F in other words to
put this and still another perspective
remember that G was a member of the
family described by integral f of X DX
to indicate that I'm going to compute G
of B why not put a B on top of this
integral sign and then to indicate that
I'm going to subtract from that G of a
why not denote G of a by the same
integral sign with an A underneath it
and then symbolically I can think of G
of B minus G of a as being this
expression here which I will then
abbreviate as you see in other words
I'll take this thing and say ok this is
now an abbreviation for what we have
here in other words that when you see
this thing which we'll call the definite
indefinite integral f of X DX from A to
B this is just an abbreviation for what
G of X G of B minus G of a where G is
any function whose derivative is f and
with this in mind now I can summarize
our lecture as follows suppose I know
that dy DX is f of X where X is defined
on the closed interval from A to B
then the change in Y on this interval in
other words the change in Y as X goes
from A to B is given by the symbol a to
integral A to B f of X DX where this
symbol is defined to be G of X evaluated
between x equals a and x equals B
meaning G of B minus G of a where G is
any function whose derivative is f
notice again that in closing that this
particular symbol here as far as I'm
concerned is artificial I don't really
need it and whereas it might have been
unfortunate to invent the phrase
definitely definitely indefinite
integral it might be even more
unfortunate to have two words sounding
so much alike that are completely
different in other words notice that
when I write the integral sign from A to
B f of X DX what this thing denotes is a
number it's a change in Y without the
two numbers here a and B this denotes a
set of functions namely all functions
whose derivative with respect to X is f
of X well at any rate I hope that this
straightens out if nothing more the
difference between the words definite
and indefinite and we shall return to
the subject called our turn to the
subject called integral calculus and
bring this up in more detail from a
different context in a little while in
the meantime we'll have a little sojourn
into the circular functions and revisit
trigonometry for a few days while we
allow this idea here to set more firmly
in your mind so until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate